[Music]
fellas everyone here is the best there
is who the hell are they gonna get to
teach us
phoenix is definitely a tough cookie she
doesn't underestimate anyone and she's
very loyal you're my new backseater he's
not cut out for this mission don't take
the bait bob
she's probably the leader of the group
her leadership qualities come through
quite a bit don't call what do you want
to do we're close stay on target
what do we have here yeah here i thought
we were special fellas this here's
bagman hang man whatever what the hell
kind of mission is this
[Music]
everyone here is the best there is who
the hell are they gonna get to teach us
captain pete maverick mitchell
let me be perfectly blunt you are not my
first choice you were here at the
request of admiral kazansky aka iceman
he seems to think that you have
something left to offer the navy
what that is i can't imagine
all due respect sir i'm not a teacher
i just want to manage expectations
what the hell
good morning aviators
this is your captain speaking
and we're off
here
we're going into combat on a level no
living pilot's ever seen
not even him
you think up there you're dead believe
me
my dad believed in you
i'm not gonna make the same mistake
[Music]
someone's not coming back from this
those are your pilots
anything happens to them
you will never forgive yourself
no turning back now come on
[Music]
yet
[Music]
[Music]
you